what is going on everybody and welcome
to another robotics with the raspberry
pi tutorial video we're going to build
off the last video and this time we're
going to take away all user control and
let the car control itself
we still only have one sensor in the
front i might do another video later
with the sensor in the rear as well so
two sensors i bought a bunch of these
distance sensors so maybe we'll do that
after that we would be out of gpio pin
so we'll see i also picked up a camera
so we'll probably have a video where we
add a camera to that and for this video
we'll take away user control but we'll
end up adding user control back once we
have the camera
just to play around with the camera and
kind of remote controlling via a camera
so that'll be kind of fun i also have
some parts already and then other parts
are on their way for a quadcopter and
that'll probably be my main focus in the
next month or so so
stay tuned for that too and start
collecting some quadcopter parts if
you're interested so with that let's go
ahead and get started there's a few
minor housekeeping things we need to do
but for the most part changing to
autonomy is relatively simplistic so
let's go ahead and get started the first
thing we want to do is change directory
in robotics and in there we have
sensor.pi
i've already changed my sensor.pi but
i'll at least explain what the change
was it was pretty simple small change so
go sudo nano sensor.pi
and once you're in there you're going to
want to come to the bottom this part
you want to comment out print distance
cm
we don't want to print that every time
we import because if you import this
it's going to do that the other thing we
already had to try and accept here but
we're passing on the exception now say
distance equals 100 and then run
gpo.cleanup of course and return
distance because that's going to become
a problem later on when we start
checking for distance very frequently
and if it's less than something we want
to do something
so before it was returning none and none
is less than 20. so it becomes an issue
so anyways once that's done escape out
of there make sure you save it and now
we're going to do is go sudo nano
robot
robot 5. pi
and now we're going to make some small
changes here the only thing we want to
import is going to be import random
we're going to use that just so it's it
does some random stuff for us
the next thing we want to do
is we want to go ahead and comment out
all this key input stuff we'll come back
to it later but for now add three
three quotes above that
and then after this add another three
code quotes doesn't make it clear that
that's commented out but it is so
uh just know that that's the case
now what we want to do is let's go ahead
and just make a simple define
auto um
actually this costs autonomy
auto probably would conflict with some
other name that exists
so anyways define autonomy one two three
four time frame is going to equal 30
milliseconds 0.030
and then
for
x is going to equal random die
rand range
zero to four basically what this is
going to do is it's going to give us a
number zero one two or three not four
and we're gonna use this to just do
random
things okay now before i forget let's go
ahead and save this and overwrite or not
overwrite rather we're going to save it
but we're actually going to call it
robot six dot pi now that we've made
some changes so make sure you do that um
yes that's fine and now sudo nano robot
six step i
come back down to the bottom
and basically what we're going to do now
is x equals random range right so now
we're just going to have what do we do
if it's a 0 what do we do if it's a 1
whatever we do is 2 3. what we're going
to do is have it do a movement so let's
say it's a zero we're gonna have it move
forward now you want it to move forward
for more than like point three seconds
right or thirty milliseconds let's say
we want it to move forward for longer
than that but what if we move forward
for one whole second well if we move
forward for one whole second a lot can
change as far as like how far away
something is in one second so really
while we're doing that move that whole
second we really want to be checking
distance constantly so
what i'm going to do is just make a a
quick for loop and have it run through
this for loop and then kind of do it for
about a second but we want to have it
checking distance pretty much constantly
to watch out for any objects either that
maybe were always there but we got
closer to them or some maybe something
comes into the way like an animal or
something else so
for that reason let's go ahead and come
over and now what we want to go ahead
and do
is we're going to start our if statement
so first we're gonna say if x equals
zero what do we wanna do one two three
four one two three four
well four y in range thirty what this is
gonna do is just go one two three or
yeah one two three four five seven eight
nine all the way to 30 basically it's
going to run it 30 times so 4y and range
30 what do we want to do well
um
what we need it to do first of all we
want to let's say we want to move
forward so we're going to say it needs
to initiate and then it needs to go
ahead
and go forward
for time frame but we also need to check
the front so how are we going to do that
well we probably should just write a
function that's going to check the front
so let's come up a little bit
make some space here and now we're going
to define a function called check
underscore front
empty parameters and all this function
is going to do is run the distance
command to see how close everything is
and if it is too close do something so
we'll come down
check front starts with initiate
and then we're going to say dist equals
distance because we imported distance
right
now what do we want to do
well if this let's say for now is less
than 15
what do we want to do well if it's less
than 15
let's go ahead and just have it print
out
too
close and we'll have it print out the
distance too close and then we'll just
do this too close
dist
good enough so if it's the case it's
going to print out to console what the
problem is it's going to initiate and
then it's going to run a reverse
two now of course
if we ever add a sensor to the back when
we reverse for two whole seconds we'd
also want to do a check rear right
because this is probably going to
reverse into stuff but for now this is
the best we've got so we'll do that and
then
uh and then we need to do the same thing
again because let's say it gets stuck
like let's say it's stuck between two
things it reversed for two seconds but
it might not be ready to go forward yet
so now we want to check it again so
we're going to say this
equals distance
and then again
if this is less than 15 well something
went wrong right
so then uh what are we going to do well
let's go ahead and print
again too close
and
dist
and then what we want to do is we'll go
ahead and run another initiation
and then we'll go ahead and reverse
for two seconds
and actually you know what we should do
is not reverse uh if if
if we're not gaining any more distance
away from what we need to gain so in two
seconds we should be less than or
greater than 15. but if we're not maybe
something's going wrong so maybe we
should pivot left for three seconds so
we can maybe change our direct
trajectory so to speak so a pivot left
for three
and then after we pivot left for 3
we still need to make some distance
hopefully so let's initiate again
and then we'll run reverse 2. after
typing all these initiations i kind of
want to add it back to the functions so
maybe we will
anyway
so reverse for two seconds and then we
need to
let's check distance one last time dist
equals distance
and then after this one if this does
less than 15 we could have more and more
loops like this but for now
if it's still the case we're just going
to print
too close
giving up um and then we'll just have it
spit out the distance and then here
we're gonna do a sys.exit i believe we
did import system let's go up to the top
make sure though
but i think we used it for the um yeah
so we do have cis so that's okay
um
so that's it for check front i'm gonna
go ahead and run a quick save here
um
yes because sometimes it disconnects so
i'm connected wirelessly sometimes the
signal drops and it's really annoying so
anyway i just saved it entered back into
it
coming back down now so now we've got
this whole check front
function so now what we're going to go
ahead and do
is for y in range
30 what we better do instead is let's go
ahead
and let's make another row here
and we're gonna run
check underscore
front
and just check the front
and so you can see so every 30
milliseconds is going to check the
distance and cover it so every 30
milliseconds is pretty darn good so
that'll do
well enough for now
now
that's it for that one so now we're
going to have to cover the rest of the
if statement so
l if x equals
1 what do we want to do well we're going
to say 4y in range 30 again
and we're going to do
check
front again
and then we're going to run initiate
and then we'll run a pivot
underscore left for time frame
and that's it there
forward to another l if
x equals two
for four one range
30.
what do we want to do now well first of
all we need to check underscore front
then we want to go ahead
run and initiate
and then after that let's do
turn
underscore
right
for the time frame
and then
let's do an uh turn left for this one x
equals three
four wine range
30
check
front
initiate
and then turn
left for time frame
okay so that should be it
um
scroll up
okay so we're all set there in that
function now what we want to do
is
we only have this function we're going
to have to call it into existence so
let's go ahead
and what we would do is like let's see
four z let's say
in range
we'll push it to the limit we'll let it
go 30 times um
what do we actually you know what for
now we're just going to do some simple
development before we actually use it on
the ground so we'll say for z in range
10
what do we want to do
we want to run
me
right
tommy cool okay so let's go ahead and
save that yes
make sure it's right into robot six hit
enter and now we're ready to go so right
now it shouldn't hit anything
you can see that my distance sensor is
kind of pointed down a little bit let me
see if i can fix that
that's a little better anyway this is
kind of loose uh so now we're ready to
run it let's go ahead and do
um
sudo python robot6.pi now what it should
do is do a bunch of forward maybe
maneuvers
um
turn all that kind of stuff and then i
have a trusty little box here and when i
put that trusty box in front of it it
should reverse
and if i hold it there it should reverse
then pivot then reverse
so we'll see about that and in fact
maybe i'll lift up my camera a little
bit so you can see better if it's
pivoting uh that'll do for now you can
at least sort of see both wheels
hopefully that's good enough for you
guys so let's go ahead and just hit
enter and see if it does some things
autonomously
so it's going forward
pit turning
turning forward
some pivot there
turning
good okay cool so now let's go ahead and
run it again and we'll stick this box in
front of it
and as you can see immediately when we
stick that box in front of it it turns
and it tells us it's too close and
whatnot
and now let's see if it okay it's
reversing pivoting
reversing
and that was successful so now it's
moving again
and i imagine we're going to hit 10 soon
yeah but then of course if we do this
panic
pivot
still in trouble
and too close giving up shutdown okay
so
so our bodies doing everything as we
expected so that's good now the real
test is to go ahead and put it on the
ground and see what happens so that's
what we're going to be doing next so uh
let's go ahead and do that